hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde da die letzte episode
ebay fail zu mega gut bei euch ankam
dachte ich mir dass ich direkt noch eine
folge rau sei ja ich würde sagen wir
fangen auch direkt an mit dem ersten
feld denn hier bietet jemand eine
trailerpark karte für hamburg und jemand
fragt daraufhin tauschte auch gegen
hamburg die karte ist für hamburg weiß
also würden sie tauschen hamburg gegen
hamburg warum weil ich mal was tauschen
will diese leute die auf ebay immer
sachen tauschen wollen sind auch so
komisch zum beispiel beim nächsten
felder verkauft jemand eine ein terabyte
playstation 4 pro und ein interessent
schreibt ihm hey tauscht du auch gegen
was gps 4 1 terabyte die von mir ist
doch auch eine ein terabyte ps4 meine
ist aber eine normale keine pro aber
wieso soll ich gegen eine schlechtere
tauschen denn er sein dass du dumm bist
lost idioten auch hier
da möchte man den fernseher kaufen
schreibt dementsprechend würde tv geld
kaufen wäre 80 euro möglich wo ist das
kann nachher vorbeikommen und der
verkäufer möchte halt 150 euro dafür
haben
daraufhin schreibt der interessent mehr
als 100 geht leider nicht biete 75 an
und da denke ich mir einfach nur so
produkt ist mit dem preis runter
das macht kein sinn la verhandlungen das
sieht dann auch der verkäufer sohn
schreibt wird ja immer weniger daraufhin
hat der interessent allerdings einen
glasklaren konnte am start und schreibt
naja gerät wird doch immer älter
[Musik]
hier wird ein spiegel mit beleuchtung
verkauft allerdings hat die person die
die anzeige auf ebay gestellt hat
wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein klein
autokorrektur fehler drin gehabt denn
sie schreibt spiegel mit beleidigung
seit 25 jahren einen spiegel mit
beleidigung noch da ja bleibt auch so
knecht
einfach mal freundlich frage ob das
produkt noch verfügbar diese person hat
das handy wasser verkauft hat gerade
verschickt und daraufhin schreibt der
käufer danke und sechs tage später alles
bestens danke nochmals weil das produkt
hat angekommen ist daraufhin antwortet
der verkäufer wiederum schön freut mich
dann viel spaß mit dem handy und eine
woche später schreibt der käufer hey ich
musste dir nochmals danken die klappbare
schutz case ist ein traum ein love
samsung danke alles wie neu die
ohrstöpsel genial und sogar mit extra
stopp systems ich küsse deine eier bei
was und genau das
nachdem auch endlich diesen fällen
gesehen haben da verschenkt neben nicht
jemand eine küche und jemanden
antwortete daraufhin hallo ich bin
geradezu der adresse gefahren da war
keiner und ich habe die tür mit meinem
generalschlüssel aufgemacht wir
montieren die küche schon mal ab und
nehmen die mit keine sorge die tür ist
nicht beschädigt worden wenn sie
vorbeikommen wollen wir sind noch circa
eine stunde hier schöne grüße und die
person antworte darauf hin ich hoffe
dass das ein scherz ist das mein voller
ernst wir sind noch hier
ich brauchte die küche alt ganz dringend
tut mir wirklich leid aber ich muss am
montag arbeiten das schaffe ich das
nicht übrigens war das im nachhinein
alles nur ein job bei der typ die
polizei gerufen hat und da war dann
niemand zu hause und er hat sie nun spaß
erlaubt weil man alleine nie seine
adresse einstellen sollte und da könnt
ihr auch was lernen leute gibt online
keine warten von euch an
es gibt noch eine website die im
internet eigentlich besuchen sollte beim
nächsten ebay verkauft die man einen
alten monitor für 10 euro und das ist
wirklich nicht viel geld allerdings
schreibt ein interessent ihn trotzdem an
und schreibt würden sie mit dem preis
noch etwas runter gehen viele grüße
daraufhin schreibt der verkäufer hallo
wie weit unten hätten sie denn den preis
gerne ich finde den euro schon sehr
niedrig liebe grüße lukas ich würde mich
freuen wenn sie den monitor verschenken
das ist
taktik die man nicht immer anwenden kann
ob jetzt im restaurant oder im kaufhaus
ist bleibt eigentlich immer hier haben
wir wieder einen autokorrektur fehler am
start und zwar verkauft dort jemand
einen die drei fragezeichen buch in den
titel der anzeige schreibt allerdings
buch von die drei fragwürdigen was ich
auch sehr unterhaltsam fand war diese
anzeige hier der verkauft nämlich jemand
den deutschen mannschaft zum bus für 500
euro und schreibt sogar den titel da
oben seht ihr ja nur vier mal benutzt
und unten auch noch bringt mehr ps als
die mannschaft auf den rasen allein nur
vier mal benutzt so gut hier verkauft
jemand für zehn euro einen original
burger king plastik strohhalm und da
denk ich mir entgegen die man von euch
noch capri sonnen zu hause hat mit einem
plastik stroheim bewahrt die auf sind in
zehn jahren das doppelte wert das
doppelte wert heute nicht so voll viel
an vietoris nach capri 20 cent oder so
viel verkauft jemand ein schlafsofa mit
liege funktion allerdings hat er auch
irgendwie der autokorrektur angehabt und
dem titel der anzeige steht schlafsofa
mit lügen funktion
ich will nicht wissen wie viele eben
darin schon kaputt gegangen sind verrät
wegen liebhaber weiter mit diesem
behringer subwoofer b 1200 de proaktiv
12 zoll
da schreibt nämlich jemand hype mit
versand bietet 100 euro der verkäufer
schreibt daraufhin mit fast 190 wohnen
sie rostock zu weit weg
120 euro kannst du mir die bringen bitte
und dann schreibt der verkäufer ihm halt
einfach einen screenshot von der strecke
die erfahren muss und das ist nämlich
diese hier einfach achteinhalb stunden
und hat dann auch ein bisschen nun
schreibt pass auf ich nehme mir ganz
spontan morgen frei steigt gleichem
einen autofahrer knapp neun stunden zu
dir dann neun stunden zurück und
verballert dabei ungefähr 120 euro sprit
das macht wichtig sind bis gleich
ironie muss wirklich gelernt sein als
nächstes haben wir einen ps3 controller
der mit leichten gebrauchsspuren für 20
euro verkauft wird und die leichten
gebrauchsspuren sehen so aus es geht
noch um beim nächsten ebay fehler wir
wieder eine person die wirklich
überhaupt nicht mit dem preis klarkommt
ich denke mir einfach nur so da du
siehst auf ebay einen preis für den ist
die person verkaufen möchte dann
verhandelt doch nicht auch noch vor
allem wenn das ganze kostenlos ist da
verschenkt nämlich immer ein bügelbrett
und jemand schreibt guten tag ist das
bügelbrett noch da ich würde das gern
neben liebe grüße hallo also da können
sie sich so abholen würden sie mit dem
preis noch etwas runter gehen
es ist doch schon umsonst weit herunter
kann ich nicht das ist halt das ding
dicker zu viele leute sind da so am
arsch und so viele leute haben auch
einfach eine autokorrektur wo ist das
beginnt fisch oder gar im nächsten gfl
wird eine tasche verkauft und nach
zahlreichen hin und her verhandeln
zwischen verkäufer und interessenten hat
die interessenten angeschrieben helfen
ein paar tage bedenkzeit schreibt
daraufhin allerdings ich nehme die
tasche aber sicher keine sorge der
verkäufer schreibt daraufhin ok und
einen tag später schreibt die
interessenten an hey du habe heute
leider mit der post einen brief bekommen
dass ich eine haftstrafe antreten muss
kann dann leider nichts mit der tasche
anfangen danke für deine liebe grüße
bekommst trotzdem der top-bewertung ich
hoffe mal dass du dann auch das
gefängnis verlassen kannst wegen der top
die fortschritte werde immer schlechter
hier verkauft jemand eine fritzbox 7530
warum ich werde diese namen nicht
verstimmt haben die schon 7530
verschiedene fritz box office bust egal
warum er halt nicht einfach fritzbox 8
oder so oder sie auf jeden fall schreibt
ein interessent guten abend ich biete
ihnen 70 euro inklusive versand an kann
sofort per paypal zahlen liebe grüße
zwei tage später schreibt er am hallo
und dann noch mal ein tag später habe
ist mein vater er hat sich auch nie bei
mir gemeldet
bei ihm ja auch nicht hier schreibt der
liebe tom hey können sie den preis
runtergehen und michael antwortete
daraufhin ja okay und geht den preis
runter er ist gut das gibt dir mach ich
auch auf sand mail glaube ich bei
unserem drittletzten ebay für heute weil
der liebe freunde wird tatsächlich ein
luxuriöser gegenstand verkauft und zwar
ein designer wasserhahn oder wie er
schreibt das ist ein die seien eher
wasser fahren ja machen wir allerdings
nur noch direkt weiter
mit dem vorletzten ebay fällt denn hier
wird ein iphone 6 verkauft und der
verkäufer schreibt nein das handy
funktioniert ohne probleme
sie können das gerne auch testen das
lässt sich der interessant natürlich
zweimal sagen und schreibt wäre es in
ordnung wenn ich das handy zu hause
testen würde für einen tag und wenn es
mir gefallen sollte würde ich es am
nächsten tag zahlen es kommt für den
verkäufer allerdings überhaupt nicht in
frage und er antwortet daraufhin ein
damit wäre ich nicht einverstanden sie
könnten es vor ort so lange sie wollen
testen der interessent bietet ihm
daraufhin allerdings ein angebot an und
schreibt ich würde auch mein hund bei
ihnen zu hause lassen als fand und an
der
wenn er lieben freunde würde ich das
heutige videos auch beenden wenn euch
ebay fans mit luca mal wieder gefallen
das kann einen daumen hoch unter video
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr neue videos nicht
verpassen wollt und wir beenden das
ganze video hier heute noch mit einem
reim und zwar rose sind rot wer jetzt
neben mir dieser typ mit glatze
ich landete leider betrunken im bett mit
matze